There's a single reason why most people
stay broke and most businesses stay
small. So, I've been in business for 14
years. [music] I have a portfolio
companies, acquisition.com, that last
year did over $250 million in aggregate
revenue. And the number one excuse that
I hear from entrepreneurs about why they
haven't grown is that their market is
[music] saturated. It's too small.
There's so many people. It's super
competitive. It's red ocean. Everyone
has these different terms. Like, I don't
want to start this thing because there's
so many people doing it. Here's what's
insane. 99% of people who say this are
completely wrong. And so unless you're
selling to 140 people in a rural town in
the middle of nowhere, your market is
probably a hundred or a thousand times
bigger than you think. And the average
entrepreneur has tapped into less than
1% of the actual market. And so there is
a massive gap between how you see your
market, how you perceive your market,
how big it actually is. Once you figure
that out, you'll realize you've been
looking at your business through a
keyhole when there's actually a massive
door in front of you that you can open
up and see what it truly is. And so what
I'm about to tell you completely change
how you see your business's potential is
total addressable market. And you'll see
why it's actually good to go into
saturated markets. Why red oceans could
actually be an amazing opportunity for
you. And it starts with understanding
why this limiting belief exists to begin
with. For the most part, in my opinion,
is that people want to protect their
egos. They say that their market is too
small. And that's the reason they
haven't been able to scale. I can't
scale my ads past $1,000 a day because I
think I've saturated my market. No, bro.
You haven't saturated your market. You
haven't saturated Facebook. Your ads
suck. You don't know different levels of
awareness. You only know how to
advertise to an avatar that understands
the solution and product that you're
selling. As soon as you get above that,
there's a much larger market above that
that could actually buy your stuff. But
because you don't know how to advertise,
you're unable to reach it. And rather
than say, I do not know how to advertise
in a way that gets more leads. I do not
know how to to scale. Instead, you say
the market is too small. real. Now, I
want to be clear here. If you have a
local business, it is possible, like my
140 person example, it is possible that
you're in a market that literally
there's there's 140 people in your
market and you're in the middle of the
Sarah desert. Yeah, it's probably not
going to work. But most of the time,
even in local markets, if you're in like
an A, you know, or A market or B market,
there's a million people in your city,
there's 400,000 people in your city, if
you need 200 to make business work, you
are fine. There's other things that are
holding you back. If you're in basically
any other industry, which you can look
up from like Google industry revenue,
the likely that you have tapped your
market, it's almost impossible. And the
thing is is that it is still one of the
most commonly stated things and least
commonly true. And so I'll tell you a
quick story about this and then I want
to show you a really powerful visual.
When I had gym launch, I wanted to start
doing outbound. Rather, I didn't want to
start doing outbound. I was convinced to
do outbound because the story about
site. So I had a conversation with uh a
guy who was a lead sales rep. He was we
were going to we were recruiting him in
and I asked him how they currently get
leads at his company and he was actually
in the gym business. I didn't find this
out until I got into the interview and
he was selling uh gym software. I asked
him how much they were doing a month and
they were doing um 10 million a month
and I was like holy canoli. I've never
even heard of this business. And I said,
"Okay, well then how are you getting all
your leads?" He said, "Oh, we just do
outbound." And I was like, "That's
insane. I didn't know outbound could
generate that kind of demand." But here
was this company that I had never heard
of that at the time was doing five times
more revenue than I was doing and it
broke a belief for me. So let me give
you this this visual that I think is
super powerful for understanding this.
So let's imagine that this is 100% of
the pie. This is the entirety of the
market, right? So if you had 100% access
to the market, you'd be super happy. Now
this is what happens in people's minds
when a competitor comes in. So you say,
"Oh my god, there's them and there's me.
Oh, I guess I will be medium happy about
this situation." And then let's say you
have
two more competitors that come in.
Now you're very sad because you're like,
"Wait, I used to have this whole pie.
Now I only have a quarter of the pie."
This is false. This belief set will keep
you poor or at least poorer than you
would otherwise be if you adopted a
different perspective. So you currently
advertise in one way using one specific
platform and one specific medium on that
platform. And so this little this little
red let's red slice of pie here, right?
What is it in in actuality? Well, let me
show you.
This is what that little slice of pie
looks like
when we actually consider the size of
the market and the aggregate attention
that exists. It's so small you can
barely even see that it's happening. And
this could be just all the different
platforms on which content, let's say
content is how you get your customers.
Maybe this is Instagram, this is
Facebook, this is Tik Tok, this is uh
YouTube, this is X, this is radio, this
is TV, this is tabula, this is Google
search, this is direct mail, this is
email, right? Like you can keep going.
This is school. All of these and you're
here and you're saying, "Hey, I think
I've cut my market into like there's
only there's only uh I only have a
quarter of the market that's available
to me." But wait, there's more.
We still have our ads circles which
you're currently doing nothing with.
Just imagine all these circles fill up
as fast as I can. And then wait, but
wait there's more.
Now we have our outreach.
And on here we could do direct mail. We
could do DMs. We could do DMs on
Facebook. We could do DMs on LinkedIn.
We could do DMs on Tik Tok. We could do
phone calls. We could do um every single
way that you can contact another human
being one-on-one is the different ways
that you could outreach. And so when we
look at this whole thing, you had two
competitors or three competitors, one,
two, and three that came into your
marketplace and you said, "Oh,
therefore, this is now super crowded."
But the reality is that you're this tiny
little sliver of this one way that that
you get customers on this one tiny
platform and I haven't even added in the
next layer of this, which is on that one
platform. Are you maximizing every way
to advertise on there? I make a couple
Instagram posts. Okay, cool. Are you
making stories? Are you making images?
Are you making carousels? Are you doing
all the different ways of doing that?
Oh, I make YouTube shorts. Okay, great.
Are you making YouTube blogs? Are you
doing YouTube community posts? How many
of them are you making? I told you that
I wanted to to shift this belief for a
second. Um because many of you are not
being limited by your market. Not even
close to it. Even if you were, and I
want to make I want to take the opposite
perspective uh for this for a moment.
Let's imagine that you're in the
absolute biggest red ocean. Red ocean
being it's super populated. There's
blood in the water, right? Do you think
the business advice niche is populated?
Do you think there's a lot of red ocean
in business advice? Yeah, probably.
Right? Should I have not gotten into
this?
The bloodier the water, it means the
more fish are there. And so where
there's the fiercest competition,
there's also often times the biggest
rewards. Now, that being said, how do we
merge this concept with the idea of you
should niche down? Wait, Alex, I thought
you wrote a book that said, "Hey, the
riches are in the niches." Right? So,
how do we merge these two ideas? Let me
explain because I get questions about
this. In the beginning, you want to
artificially constrain the pond that
you're going after so that you can
compete in a place where the sharks
aren't swimming. Okay? So, you want to
be the biggest guy in a puddle. That's
what you want to do. Biggest guy in a
puddle. And then you say, "You know
what? I'm going to go from a puddle to a
pond because I think I'm I'm too big for
this puddle." And so, you grow. And then
you go to the pond. And then once you go
from the pond, you say, "You know what?
I'm going to go to a lake. Now I'm in a
lake because I'm a even bigger fishy.
Right now I'm in a lake. And then
eventually you get to the point where
you say, you know what, I think that I'm
big enough to go into open class, open
market and fight in the ocean. Now, if
we were to look at this trajectory,
I started as a trainer
and I talked about nutrition and stuff
and then I talked about gym stuff
and then I started talking about
business stuff.
So, you're going to have evolutions
where you can get big enough for a pond
that you can move on from the pond to
the lake and the lake to the ocean. It's
just that it's directly correlated with
your skill and your experience. And so,
the reason that the the riches are in
the niches is that when you're there,
number one, you're competing against
fewer people. And so, the upside is
capped typically. Now, it's usually
capped at way higher than you think it
is, but it is capped to a degree. And
that's okay. But as a result, because we
are niched down, we're able to charge
niche prices which give us more profit,
more pricing power because there's fewer
people. There's fewer things to compare
you against, right? And so there does
come a time where you can go uh move the
market, right? Move your market rather
um to go after a different segment or a
broader segment. So let me walk walk
through what you can how to think
through this evolution for a business.
So let's say that your current business
is this little dot here. Okay,
there are five directions that we can
move with this dot. We can go. So let's
imagine this is a you've got a triangle
of a marketplace. Okay, so this is where
you this is where you inhabit. You can
go up market. All right. So for example,
um in my gym launch days, I could
instead of serving single location
fragmented gym owners, I could go to
franchisers, right? multilocation owners
and franchisers. So I have oneoff gyms
here. Now the next direction, so this is
direction number one I can do. Direction
number two is I can go down market which
would be that I could go after trainers.
There's way more trainers. They have way
less buying power, but there's a lot of
them. There's fewer franchisers than
there are gyms and there's fewer gyms
than there are trainers. Pyramid, right?
So that's the second thing we can do.
The next thing we can do is we can go
adjacent.
So instead of gyms, I say, you know
what? I think I can help Cyros.
That's what I think I'm going to do. I'm
going to take my systems and I'm going
to go into chiropractors. That'd be an
adjacent market. I could also go
broader, right? Which would mean that I
would look at this way,
which means instead of gyms, maybe I
talk about health and wellness in
general. And so that means that I could
go after Cyros,
med spas,
anybody, you know, weight loss clinics,
all of these things are now broader.
Or I can go
narrower. So instead of gyms, I say I'm
only going to work with spin studios.
I'm only going to work with dancing
studios. So this is our
fifth. This is our fourth. This is our
third. So that gives you five directions
that you can go in to change the
direction of the market that you choose
to play it. Now, I outlined this and
what's interesting is that most people
who are especially smaller business
owners have never even defined this to
begin with and they pretty much just
accept people's money as long as they
have a pulse and a credit card. There's
obviously two requirements. Well, let's
say pulse is optional as long as they
have a credit card. Kidding that they
accept. But the thing is is that like
you want to get really really clear on
this because if you don't your customers
will be confused because they won't know
what you're really about. So the tactics
for you if you're like all right
I am not getting because typically
people will say that they are in too
small of a market because they're not
getting as many leads as they want which
are two completely different issues
right and so if you can at least believe
believe you know believe the idea that I
have um that there is other ways to get
customers than you're currently doing
which I'll refer to back here what you
do is you say how do I make content in
more places how do I make more of it how
do I make it better and then eventually
you say how do I also run ads? How do I
also pair outreach with that? And that
is how you can achieve omnipresence as a
business and so you need to do more in
more places even better consistently for
a long period of time because it's
unlikely that you've actually capped the
market. You are just too unskilled to
capture the significantly larger
percentage of the pie.
And that's okay. And that's what we stay
in for the short term. And then
eventually as you get better, you can
expand it and expand it and expand it
and you keep eating and that's all right
and totally normal. Real quick, I have a
gift for you. This is the $100 million
scaling road map. It's something that my
team and I put 200 plus hours into
building and breaking the stages of
scaling into 10 steps. All right? And so
what we did is we broke down everything
that got us basically got us stuck and
what we did to break free at each level
of the business. And if you'd like to
know what product, marketing, sales,
customer service, IT, recruiting, human
uh resources, and finance look like at
the stage that you're currently at, this
is a free gift. So all you have to do is
go to aquis.com/roadmap. You can plug in
your business information. And if you
want our help, you want my help to help
you break through whatever level of
scaling you're at. This is not a
promise. I'm just saying we'd love to
help. Um on the thank you page, you can
book a call. Uh every month we have a
workshop out here at my headquarters.
you actually talked to my real team that
does does our marketing, does our
emails, does our ads, does our copy,
does our does our does our sales, does
our finance, does our recruiting, the
real people are doing this at a very
high level. And what's really cool about
that is that they can typically find and
spot what the constraints are in a
business like that. And so it's one of
the most valuable things that I could
possibly do. Obviously, you know, space
is limited based on our actual
headquarters. Um, but if that's
interesting, on the thank you page, you
can book a call. No pressure. This is a
gift either way. It's absolutely free.
Now, I said at the very beginning, if
you're a local market, you can this can
sometimes bite you. So, I want to give
some of the local guys, which are
usually like 35% of people are listening
to this. Um, so I'm going to go real
quick for you guys, what you can
actually do to expand how much you can
make with just a single location. So,
number one is you can expand your actual
location. So, that means you knock down
walls, you add seats, uh you just
increase efficiency. Like, how can I get
more um from my existing four walls? How
do I get more out of it? Like for me,
um, when I started getting too crowded
at my first gym, I, you know, cut the
class times from 45 minutes to 30
minutes. Um, and by doing that, I got,
you know, one and a half times more
classes in. I cut out the like breaks
between classes, so again, I could fit
more people in. I could also extend and
open more hours. All of those things
expand your existing location. The
second thing that you can do is what I
just walked through, which is you add
more channels. So, okay, you're posting
on Instagram. Are you posting on X? Are
you posting on YouTube? Are you posting
on Facebook? Are you posting on Tik Tok?
Like you expand channels.
And I would say that many of you guys
have heard my rule of uh one avatar, one
product, one channel until you get to a
million dollars a year. The only
exception to this is sometimes local
businesses. Now, if you're in, I would
say an A or B market, you could totally
just do that to get to to get to a
million a year. if you're in like a C or
D market. So, I would say I don't know
what the numbers are there, but I'm
assuming it's probably like less than
50,000 people in like a 10 mile radius
of where you're at. If you're at less
than 50, then you're going to probably
need to use more than one channel to get
customers because there's just there's
just not as many people. You have to you
have to saturate that tiny market by
getting in in front of more people in
more places. The third thing that you
can do is you open another location.
So you can expand the current one, you
can add channels to drive even more into
the current one, but at a certain point,
you're going to max out your four walls.
And so you just open a new spot. And I
see that as the eventuality of most
these businesses. And I think this is
kind of interesting because a lot of
people feel like they're like, I don't
know if this is a $100 million
opportunity. It's like, well, yeah, your
one store isn't a $100 million
opportunity, but you being able to
duplicate and nail the model and then
scale the model absolutely is. And so if
you have the goal of getting to $10
million a year, you can pretty much do
it in any business. If you have the goal
with with the exception of if you are a
brickandmortar and there's 100 people in
your in your local market, probably not.
But out outside of that um that business
model, even if you were in a tiny
market, could get to 10 million a year,
you just open up in new markets. That's
all you do, right? Most people's goals
are achievable within their current
vehicle. They were just too impatient
and believe that there's another shiny
object that someone will get there
faster. But if you take the natural
extreme and say, "If I only did one
thing for 40 years, do I think I'd be
successful?" Probably. And so if you
knew that to be true, then that would
give you a very strong reason to stick
with whatever you're doing. Because let
me give you a visual for this. This is
the cost of switching. So if let's say
that you're in year three
of your current current business, okay,
or current opportunity, it doesn't
really matter what it is. So this is
one, this is year two, this is year
three. Okay? Now, what people want to
convince themselves is that they're
like, I want to start this new thing.
Okay, that's fine. You want to start
this new thing. So, let's see that year
one of this new thing is higher. Okay,
that's fine. This one is a little bit
higher than this one and year two. But
the thing is is that this is year one of
this year,
but it's year four here.
You're still behind. And not only that,
growth when you get bigger is easier
than growth when you're smaller.
and you're like, "Okay, well maybe maybe
this faster rate of growth I'll be able
to catch up.
Okay, well now you're year two, but now
we're at year five over here, right?"
And so the head start that you give
yourself by sticking with something like
sticking with it is how you get the head
start. It's how you keep the head start
that you already began. That's something
that I think so many people miss when
they're trying to go to this next
opportunity. Unless there is something
inherently wrong with the assumption
that you have and skill is not the
deficiency that you need to overcome,
which it often is. Most of the time,
people get stuck on things that I call
features, not bugs, and this isn't my
invention, is that there's an element of
your business that makes it hard.
There's an element of every business
that makes it hard. But that's what
makes it a business, and that's why
you're compensated for it. If you're in
the cleaning business, the difficulty
you're going to have is attracting and
retaining high-quality talent. If you're
in the fitness business, the difficulty
is attracting customers and customer
retention because people are inherently
really shaky um about staying with their
fitness goals, but they typically stick
with their cleaners for a really long
time, right? And so, every business has
elements that make it shitty. It's just
the name of the game. And you know what?
I'll give you a different frame on this.
So, if you were to think about different
business models. So, let's think about I
I doubt many of you guys have heard
this, so this is pretty sweet. So, let's
say that you've got uh e-commerce,
you've got uh let's say you've got
service,
you've got um let's say info, education,
media, and let's say you've got SAS. All
right, so software. Okay, so let's say
that these are four different
opportunities. Each of these
opportunities has a different shape.
So, info looks like this.
starts really fast, very difficult to
scale. SAS is the opposite. Starts
really, really slow, scales really,
really fast.
Ecom is more like this. You can scale
fast, but there's difficulty with
typically cash flow because you have to
continue to buy more inventory. Uh you
have supply chain issues. You have to
switch suppliers, switch 3PL so they can
handle your volume. All of this stuff
happens as you continue to grow. So,
it's more like it's more like this.
That's the shape of ecom, right? And
then service businesses are more like
this,
the slowest, but they are steady. And so
when you see these four shapes,
many of you guys just hit the crappy
part of whatever the opportunity that
you're on is, and then say there's
something wrong with my business,
therefore I should stop. Rather than
seeing it as what it is, which is this
is just the nature of how this business
works. This is a feature, not a bug.
It's going to be harder for you to
attract really good talent in
engineering and build software and
you're probably going to be not
profitable because most software sells
for lower ticket most for a period of
time and it takes a long time to get a
product to actually be good and so
you're going to basically burn money,
burn time for a long period and then
eventually you can scale to the moon but
it takes a long time sometimes years to
get there and a lot of people don't have
that level of tolerance. Info on the
other hand is kind of the exact opposite
of that. You can make a lot of money
really quickly, a lot being relative,
right? you're probably not going to
become a billionaire, but you can make a
million dollars and then very quickly it
gets very difficult to scale it.
I say like info is specifically more
like coaching, things like that. And the
reason for that is because there's
almost no no revenue retention. People
don't stay around. Once you learn
something, you learned it. That's why
people graduate school. They learned,
right? Service businesses, the issue is
people because it's a very people people
heavy business. You have to constantly
be hiring, onboarding, and training. And
it depends on the service you're
providing. If you provide weight loss
coaching service or weight loss
services, I use that as the example
obviously because I came from that. You
you have you have it's easy for you to
get talent because lots of people want
to talk about fitness and weight loss
and and and food all day because they're
like really into it. So it's actually
very easy to get good talent and for
below average prices because people
would do it for free. On the flip side,
customers never want to do it and so
they're cancelling all the time. If I
had an accounting firm, it's the
opposite. Accounting firms have super
high annual stick. What's the difficulty
with accounting firms? getting the
people who can do accounting. And it's
almost always this balance, right? If a
lot of people want to do it, there's
going to be a lot of competition.
There's very low barriers to entry. And
as a result, customers have lots of
options and they don't want to do it
themselves. If uh there aren't as many
options and you have supply constraint
industry, then you're going to have
issues getting talent fundamentally. And
you can look at this at the business
level, but you can also look at the at
the at the uh at the industry level. And
so I talk about demand constraints and
supply constraints at the business
level, but you can see if you are way
off track based on do you match with
your industry. If your industry, and by
the way, if you are if you are the
inverse of your industry, you're usually
doing something either really wrong or
really right. Side note, so great way to
think about it. If you can be supply
demand constrained in like the cleaning
business example that I gave, if you
give demand constraints as in I could
take a 100 times more customers than I
currently am with my cleaning thing,
well then you've either figured out
something really amazing with cleaners
to like attract them in and like you're
about to go hypers scale or you're just
starting out and you haven't done
anything yet. There's either something
really right or really wrong with what
you're doing. But most of the time you
probably match the same constraint of
your industry. And the problem with not
being experienced is you think there's
something wrong. And so then you end up
spending multiple years not being allin
on your opportunity and then being upset
that it's not growing as fast as you
want it to grow when in reality you
never really gave it a shot because
you're always looking. You're kind of
like the kind of like the guy who's in
the marriage that they're like, you
know, they they were in love a while ago
and you know they're things are okay but
they you know he's got a wandering eye,
right? He's always looking. He's always
pay you know trying to look for the next
thing, the next girl, the next whatever.
And he's like well my marriage isn't
good. It's like, well, no [__] You're
spending all your time looking at these
other opportunities rather than doubling
down on the thing you got. And when you
double down on the thing you got,
usually when you take the mar it takes
way less time. I would, okay, I'm not
I'm not I'm not going to make broad
sweeping statements on marriages. All
right. But I will say that in my
experience, from my N equals one
marriage, it takes way less time to go
from like we're upset about something to
we're really good than it does to create
the loyalty, the trust, and the track
record that you have from that marriage
with someone else. Real. So, um,
with that being said, that was my my
pest resistance, if you will. That was
the thing that I wanted to talk about
today that was top of mind is that so
many people think that their market is
actually limited when in reaction their
mind is limited. And there are so many
ways to advertise, but you do not have
the skill to advertise it. And so I'll
leave you with a really powerful
question that I think is worth asking
yourself uh when you're in these
situations is instead of saying there
are no good salespeople in my market or
no one can sell like I can sell or I you
know it's really crowded which really is
usually a translation for I can't get
enough leads or leads cost too much by
the way. Um but you say these statements
just frame it into a statement that you
control.
meaning I don't have the skill to get
more leads. I don't have the skill to
attract, hire, manage a good
salesperson. I don't have the skill to
get employees to behave in a way that is
according to the goals that I have in
the business. Those as soon as you state
it in that way, guess who owns the
outcome? You. You become source. You
become the one who can change it. And so
I would just like there it just does not
serve you to cast your power outside of
yourself and give that as the reason for
why you lack the success that you want.
Here's the crazy part. You could be
right.
And so what?
Like some prizes aren't worth winning.
Like if you want to play the pity game
and you want to win the pity award for
for for person who was born with most
inconveniences or person who had the
worst things happen to them, you can win
that award. The question is just do you
want it? Is that prize worth playing
for? Is it worth competing for? For me,
when I see when I hear or see a
situation like that, there's also
something that I think is the same
power, if not more powerful, which is
this person was able to win despite
that. And that's a story that only you
can have. And the more [__] up your
childhood, the more [__] up the the
things that you went through to get to
where you are are, the stronger that
story is for the people who follow
behind you and look up to you, the more
you can serve as an example for other
people who have suffered the same things
that you've suffered or suffered worse
than you suffered. And I think it's like
you rob yourself of that opportunity by
protecting your ego and saying that it
was because of this other thing. And
maybe you're right, but wouldn't it be
cooler to be right about the fact that
that was true and you won instead and
you won anyways and you succeeded
despite that? I think that's a much
cooler story. And I think that if we use
if we use the story frame, which is one
of my favorite razors, which is that
when you're 85 and you're and you're
split between two choices in life, pick
the cooler story because at the end of
your life, it's the only thing you're
going to be left with anyways. And when
you have these two choices, there's
usually the the hard thing uh which is
the right thing and the other way. And
the reason that I think you should
always take the hard thing is because if
the easy thing were the right thing, you
wouldn't have had to make this decision
because you would have already done it.
And so you're only hesitating because
it's harder than you